okay we had a look at a question just
like this question one last week
do you remember even though you can do
this by is there another way we can do
this a more efficient way yeah I did
that you subtract those two schools and
you'll end up with 94 then that's how we
pointed out to me it has to be okay so
let's just make sure we know what's
going on yeah what is this this about
what does that help us one yeah okay
very good
the beam you want to achieve and when
you add a score hunt in here you're
gonna have not three but four scores
okay so therefore by the time you add on
to that fourth score if you want the
beat of 80 over those four scores
they'll need to add up to 320 that makes
sense so it's like I've got something up
getting up to this is what I already
have I don't even know what this is but
300 something no yeah 200 yeah it's 200
something because I've already get to
320 okay so therefore if I got this
score exactly I would land on a mean of
80 exactly but we don't look at me of 80
exactly so we want to be over a so
therefore I mean I didn't say anything
about you know decimal points raised
like that and suppose you could have
said 94.1 suppose our whole numbers so I
think 95 is a good conclusion yes by the
way I just kind of think it's like this
is an actual thing because you know if
some of you guys go for a scholarship
when you go to university one of the
conditions of holding on to a
scholarship or an internship or all that
kind of thing is often they will check
the averages of your scores and they'll
say you need to get over this and you
need to keep that throughout the course
of your tertiary studies in order to
retain the scholarship so and I think
thank you
eighty-five depends on the sculpture
right so yeah there you go Catholic
XE there's one more huh agreement
heads-up agrees yeah hands up properly
okay that's better
let's quickly just I mean this should
take us too long there's not that big
move you have to do to get to a solution
in fact we could do to booze at once for
this first life that we could get to
like one time for the solution what do
you guys recognize to do so I went to
college right I've got exits on both
sides and then I've got numbers on both
sides so I'm gonna fix that in one here
I'm gonna add 3x to both sides they'll
get all the X's on one side and then
what about this guy I bet there's no bar
I'm gonna add one to both sides and
that'll get other numbers over that side
so far so good
so that would give me 6x left and one
other right nine so the x equals 9 over
6 is that one the hug okay steady
deviation so it's the kind of thing
which you need to punch through menus
yeah okay I remember this kid